哈喽同学们大家晚安
来给刚刚在问这个
这个steam的这个
这个同学
他steam买在1.24
这个根本是一个有够标准的
周线日线等级的破底翻
我的妈呀
這是什麼東西
不早講 因為你不說 可惡
然後同學問說 他這裡是不是要粗一些
我覺得你粗的很棒
你都已經從1.24 捏到2.54
翻倍了對不對
好吧 那就粗一些剛好又是壓力
然後剩下的你就給他賭賭看
這邊承受大震盪 看可不可以賭到4啊 賭到5 6這樣子
這個就是後面的事情
說不定就像前面這樣
就讓你賭成功了
好不好,這位同學真的是太棒了
耶!
那你就不用來聽了啊
你聽很熟了對不對
然後這位同學的這個我等一下
等一下我好好的聊一下好不好
等一下我先截起來這樣
然後同學我剛剛看到什麼
巨大回到成本價哪泥
例子剛剛有同學吃的
这个也是好像也可以讲的
巨大我看一下
你说回到成本价
代表你凹到下面
这个
来巨大
所以你的成本在100这边
110几
所以你的成本在这边
所以你这样凹下去又凹上来
对不对
好了
既然你都已经凹下去
凹上来
回到这边你给自己设定一个想法
第一个我不知道你有几张
既然回到成本
如果你现在全部出掉
反正你已经回本了
你可不可以当做自己重新来就好
你可不可以这样子做
都已经回本
老天爷给了你一个这个机会回本
对吗
那如果没有重来
就把资金拿去做别的单子
别的部位
這不是很好嗎所以我的建議其實是你居然給的第二次機会让你回本回到成本那我的想法是赶快先出掉吧
因为如果他接下来行情又花了三个月半年又掉到85
从111掉到85回来这里找边界
假设这个事情发生的时候
你现在回头问自己
我如果是这样子没有出
我会不会垂心肝垂到死
哇早知道我就出一出
会吧
如果会你现在就走
就是明天早上直接管他什么价格
就算跳下来都没关系
什么价格都走
这样可以吗
然后刚刚有同学问这只
3483他问的问题是什么
3483在哪里
这里
周线看起来不错
日线有点87%
来来来
这一只是
也不对
348在这里
立志
从我的角度看
我觉得这个边界经过这么明确的下引线测试
反而我会很喜欢这种股票
因为我可以很轻松的定义出打极区
稍微有点宽
但是我很喜欢这样子的概念就是
好
我不用急
这一根K-Bunk就是今天这一根
如果它的力量是真的
那我可以好好的在这个地方等待
所以我可能就先丢个十分之一的部位
十分之二的部位
慢慢试一下水温
诶对了哦
上去再回来
还在这里
诶在家在家
这样子的交易
我觉得会很适合
好不好
然后这位同学
先恭喜你
你说赚培比做到1比5
心态好多了
对嘛
就算胜率很低
20%其实算低
那我们平常做交易应该不至于到这么低
但是就算就算这么烂都可以打平
对吧
所以位置合理差不多就按看看
到目前为止有小小的盈余
好光这个小盈余
已经值得给你掌声鼓励
好不好
那你说想多做一口到1比10的话
我建议我都先做到1比5
然后记录一下成功的单子有多少
後來跑到1比10這就衡量
不用這樣記錄
為什麼呢
因為每一次就算你前面記錄了9次10次裡面有9次都走出去你有可能接下来连续9次都走不出去对吧长期下来
它不可能是
它应该会约略在一个平均值左右
但是它不可能一定是两次就中一次
两次就中一次
没有这么刚刚好
有些时候你一天中好几次
有些时候一天都是三症
回帮落空
也有可能
这样
所以不用刻意这样子
那你说你想要再扩大
我会建议你做2的倍数的部位
2 4 6 8 10
反正就是做你可以出1留1的部位
所以你到1比5的时候
其中一半的部位先走
把你原来该做的就直接走掉
然后另外一半就给他堵
堵到后面这一段再翻上去
这样子就很OK
这样好不好
你先这样子做
你会发现这样子做
又会把我们的赚倍比再一度的拉开来
虽然你前面一开始承受的风险是两个风险
因为你原本只有一个部位
你现在下两个部位
但是这两倍的风险
所带来的利润却远远超过十倍
甚至有可能十多倍
我说用风险的角度来衡量的话
这是很值得的事情
这种初一流一
卖掉巨大买国巨好像可以
对好要来听不然怎么会有这支
同学帮我回答的很棒
如果你所交易的商品是成交量很低
很冷门的商品
或是热门的商品在冷门时段
或是你切到很冷门的刻度
可能1K里面去找股票
但你也看不到
看不到标准图
因为它需要足够的成交量
我也没有办法告诉你
足够到底
什么叫做足够
这很难说
但基本上
我希望那个交易量是
全部的人大家都在做的那种东西
那么那个交易量
跟K棒的样子
就很容易是我們看得懂的樣子
那這樣的好處是什麼
因為大家都參與了很多人參與他的價格動態所涵蓋的心理層面的變化就會很準確因為只有一個人的心態怪怪的那不重要
兩個人
一千個人
兩千個人
兩萬個人的心態
都受同樣的這個價格所驅動的時候
那就好玩了
我喜歡玩這種事情
OK
來
那
新书
我说我现在这个月
我就是在来回跟书上教稿
他们还在等我这边
陆续把我的章节的那个图片
标上编号
编号几支几
几支几的这个
我顺便就regoi是我的书
然后把编号标给他们
上周台子算不算
好我看一下
我看一下台值
台值我就用这个看好了
上周你会用14点应该是7月30
这里对不对
你是指这里吗
这超美啊
这个就是我人在日本错过的点
就是这个
这个
这个是我目前看起来
这个而且他刚好又是什么东西
来各位
我们其实讲这个整数关卡讲很多次
对吧
今年能出一定可以
因为不至于到那么久
因为现在是书已经好了
都给他们了
然后就只是在做这个边编号等等的事情
这个动作只能我做
因为他们不知道图几支几
是要搭配哪几句话这样子
这个超美
但是我超讨厌这个位置
因为那个时候我人在旅游
我觉得我以后可能要重新选时间
连我上个礼拜我出差去那个
我不是去台北录影吗
我录那个TVBS财经的那个节目
结果呢
我去的那天
就Jack在吃的那个60分K的小娜
他吃在底下这里
来来来
这个等一下我来聊
他吃在
吃在这里
Jack是在这边的小娜
这里
这个是我很会做的东西
然后他就这样给我转出去
气死
好吗
我今天的NQ是在这里
我今天的NQ
我交代一下我今天的NQ好了
我把那个叫出已完成
我在这边花了两次的停损
我先下三口而已
四口
所以我的停损加起来
大概才200 300左右
不多
我花了两次的停损
才逮到这个机会
这个
那我吃的东西
我看能不能放更大一点点
这样子
吃停損
這個只有三口
因為我知道很摸
所以我就吃三口而已很小部位
這邊這個
這個是看到這邊下不去好了
摸摸看就一剛摸完
蹦就下去了
隔壁這個又重來
好這個當時我下的單子是
是我下多少四口嗎
應該是吧
我下四口
然後後來
回來到這裡
這個點我多加碼一次
所以变成五口在手上
所以眼前就是就是这样子
那各位应该很清楚知道我在这边下单的
这边下单的这个想法吧
这是什么
这什么东西
你切
30K应该很清楚
来
30K 60K各位这是什么东西
破底方
我没有话很精准
但是你知道我的意思
这样
所以我是在大科度的边界
那底下这个你在摸什么来来来
這個我再摸這個
這個呼喚
這是我從日本回來到現在第一次出手
因為錯過這邊
超悶
所以我的悶
我自己覺得我悶在那種
看著大家我明明會做
但是都吃不到
很悶
然後呢
所以我現在從悶悶的感覺要走出來
我不希望我一次就給他10口20口的部位敲下去
我覺得這樣子我很容易把那個錯過的情緒帶進這個市場裡面
所以我就用用短線的角度吃
然後用小口數這樣子
好然後來講一下我這些在幹嘛
這個是我早上那時候吃的單子
但是他剛好這個地方沒有被打到停順
這裡呢被打掉以後這邊
這邊陸陸續續我有吃然後打掉打掉
這個是吃加碼打在中間不賠吃加码下来吃加码不赔打掉这个阶段是我女儿的同学们
就是来我家我就一起交交易的东西
那正好就在我眼前
我就跟他们讲好
就在这里吃干嘛干嘛
这些交易某个程度来说
带着示范给他们看的意味
你说这么摸的单子吗
我們當時不是
我們當時在1K裡面
看一下
這個單子我好像是看5K吃的
我就忘記
應該是5K
尖尖的隔壁吃的概念
這邊好像也是5K
到這個來
各位這個我在1K吃
因為我正在教他們這樣
這個
請問
這裡有
有沒有符合我們的交易邏輯
邊界
尖尖的隔壁這裡
这时候人他们人在我们家客厅
我各位看到那个线洞
就是女儿说猫
那就是我正在教他们的时候的东西
这样
然后这个
这个是当时在他们在他们前面
然后就说示范说这样子的交易怎么样
我在大科度的边界怎么摸
这样子
然后这里也是这些都是在
注意看哦
我仍然是躲在人家后面
对吧
只是没有成功而已
这时候拉个不赔
他们要离开的嘛
我就拉个不赔
结果就这样子
所以只有我自己个人的账号这边
这里有一路做出去
这样好不好
NQ现在看有点假突破的感觉
来给这位同学
我们假突破的样子
涂鸦
請問從我的塗鴉
我用粗一點的畫筆
我刻意用比較粗的
紫色好了
各位看一下
我從這邊開始塗鴉過去
塗鴉到端點
注意看我的端點
我這個比較仔細一點
這邊注意看
重點要來了
好 我都要到这里 请问跟我们假突破的样子
假突破关心的点是这个嘛 请问这两张图像吗一秒钟告诉我像吗没有嘛那就没有啦
如果这里要符合假突破
那中间这一段他需要这样子
需要
长出去
快速的下来
又来到这里
如果是这样子来到这个地方
我会跟你说哦
这个地方
空方很棒哦
因为有这个上不去
上去的又掉进来哦
这个地方空方很棒
给那位问假突破的同学
有解决到你的疑问吗
这样应该可以对吧
然后在这个这周的过程中
我还多吃了一个单子是这个
这个SpaceX的选择权
这样我吃在这个地方
这样那我吃的时候我吃了10口
就是10口也不多
当初的投资的这个金额也不过才
反正大概翻倍了
大概3000多美金
然后现在就就变到
加起来变成8300
那这个对我来讲
我把它当成是现货的感觉
反正我就在底下吃选择选
而且我吃的是吃到9月18
也就是说结算的这个时候
所以中间呢
如果差不多再继续喷
我应该就会适当的收一收
可能留个一些
然后呢
我看到的是在这里吃的
所以我是在这个地方
看到这个SpaceX的边界吃的
这样
好不好
所以眼前的这些部位
大概就是
就是这样
同学说看到小10K
来来来
让我们看一下小10K
你在看的是不是这个
看的是不是这个
来我跟你说
这个假突破的东西
在第一次掉进来
回来测的这里
这里已经用过了
它用过了那个力量
也就是说现在你要重新的用
两条线的边界来看这件事
而不是继续专注在刚刚的假突破
如果这个假突破成立
照道理讲这边就要下去才对
这样
所以现在就是夹在这个中间
而且上面喔
它其实有蛮多K棒来撞上面这里这里这里所以你不要画这里今天这个地方正好可以拿来教学当做今天的课Peter
你是在我后面装了摄影机是不是
超恐怖的
你为什么可以接我的话
好恐怖
以前你在群组里面
我就感觉到你应该是有在监视我的萤幕
那你应该会看到很多优雅才对啊
没有啦我有好几个萤幕
我会在那个你没有监视的萤幕
来算不算空方的边界二
坦白讲我觉得还不是很算
你知道为什么吗
因为一个空方喜欢的
Peter是不是坐在旁边
對沒有啊旁邊沒人啊
這要怎麼練很難說好不好
我先回答同學的問題
我先從我看一下
我先把今天的主題開始慢慢講
然後一路講到大家同學的問題這樣好不好
很多人來碰不算牆壁的確很算牆壁
但是他比較尷尬
因為從我的角度看 看一下這邊
我用比較大的圖畫好了 看這裡
這張圖現在的EK界我用
我喜歡的邊界是這樣子跟這樣子
我希望它乾乾淨淨 注意看喔
如果上邊界這裡是尖尖的朝外
然後隔壁在這邊出發往下對不對
隔壁換個顏色 這裡出發往下
假設是這樣子
那这个尖尖的就只能有他自己
跟我早上做的那个1K的这个
来
这个
这个1分K的这里
戳出去的只有他一个人
其他都没有了
如果这边多一个尖尖的在这里
哇
那会很难判断
就是他的边界到底是我画的这一条呢
还是底下这边呢
哇
这是一个问号很难判断的东西
所以我们这个角度回来看
看刚刚你的这里
他的上边界来看一下
有这个人
有
這裡有很多個人
但是最近的兩個60k
好像都有碰到這邊跟這邊
你懂我意思嗎
有點
不是那麼好判斷
然後同時間的這個地方你看我現在這條邊界
我知道這裡容易上不去
我現在也知道
但是他不容易抓邊界
除非你進到更短刻度裡面
5分K
5分K我也看不到好東西
因为5分K我看到的是
是这样子
然后这个涂鸦
虽然没有到很漂亮的一直往上走
但是我看到的是底部一直垫上去
好吗
我想要赌到美股开盘以后
因为我喜欢赌这个
反正我现在已经不会赔钱
我还拉了小小的利润
一点点
我想要赌这个
这个
我想要赌这个到3万出去
这样
这个的读法大概就是跟前几天如果是
大家我去看Jack的那单
大家自己去Jack的网页里面
他的FB里面看他这一单
他吃在这边
这边
还记得我们说过吗
尖尖的左边跟尖尖的右边距离差不多
所以这边怎么下来
这边很容易就怎么上去
对吧
就这样子上去了
那我现在尖尖的的左边
跟尖尖的右边
是不是又是类似的
而且这个时间点是不是又是正好
是我们台湾时间的欧洲盘开盘时间
这些我早就讲到烂掉了
对不对
然后出现这样子
那我就是要干嘛
就是要干嘛
对嘛
把它做出去
这样
那我会不会赌输
有
但是现在来讲
我不会输了
我这个今天目前之前赔的钱
前面几次测试的钱都回来了
所以我宁愿就是不赔打掉
我想要赌赌看
这样子
那我喜欢赌这种
而且我的部位其实也才五口
如果我是这边有下五
这边又下一个五
我有十口的话
我现在大概就会减四
只留下六口
这样子
如果我有比较多的部位
现在部位只有五口那就抱着啊就抱就抱抱看啊 看會發生什麼事這樣子好嗎然後
我還沒開我的投影片
大家等我一下好不好
投影片
這個等一下要聊的東西 等我一下 我開一下投影片
那我先他在打开的时候
标准图两种稍微勾起来才买
稍微勾起来是到什么程度
给这位同学请你去看
我在这个频道的新手训练的那个新手必看的专区里面
观念篇有几支关于尖尖的大绝招
就是我在讲尖尖的隔壁这件事情
請去看這個好不好
然後我講互換好了
一個互換好了
我會需要他這裡稍微勾起來
那這個稍微勾起來的概念
重點不是在於勾的這一根
而是勾的這一根出現以後他底下的
這個邊界
那通常勾起來的時候行情會是像這樣子
我找一下
有沒有互換的可以用
如果这边这边借我用假设这边要出现互换
我不要用小时k我看5分k有没有
5分k有类似的
这个我需要他是由上往下
所以他这边开始你看像这里开始有人起来了以后重点不是起来多久
而这个案例我觉得也没有到很美我这边一看就撞墙
借我用好不好
假装没有那么有压力
我的重点就是上去以后回来的这里勾起来以后
我就知道这个边界有人用
所以当他再度回来这个边界
并且开始长出一点点的下影线
好
那我就来干嘛
我就来跟着吃
跟着前面这个有力量
有力量弯上来的这一个人
我跟着他的力量吃
这个概念大概是这里
有力量弯上来以后在后面跟着弯上来这个人的底部
你在这附近跟着跟着这样子吃这边的部位
大概是这种概念是说这个我觉得没有到很美是因为他又有支撐又有壓力的樣子我說這個只是我眼前看到這邊我就只好拿他來當舉例
這樣好不好
所以你先這位應該是楊同學吧
你先去把那個裡面的那個尖尖的
你Google搜尋
在這個YouTube裡面搜尋尖尖的關鍵字
去把那個大絕招看完
这样好不好
我的那个投影片我已经打开了
在这里
所以我们来聊今天的这个主题
好了
那刚好今天前面这些案例都是很值得拿来讲的
你等一下都会都会聊到这样子
好不好
来
哪个才是对的压力支撑
你们看的跟我看的都不一样
那我们今天会从看得出边界
一路到怎么进场
事实上我刚刚前面在讲
我自己的交易的时候
我都已经很明确的跟大家讲
我看到什么东西
那我在哪里吃
在哪里干嘛
对吧
所以刚好都有显示出来
来咯开始
先回来
刚好就是这位亚萍同学的东西
黄金买在4120
刚好你在线上太好了
太好了
我们直接看一下你的黄金
你说你买在4120
我有一个好
有个问题想要问你
4120的价格是在这里
那你是在哪个地方买到4120的
你是买在这里吗
这里吗
不管你买哪一个位置
我看起来都不像我们的买法
所以我在猜你可能是用追突破的买法
可能买在这或买在这
或是下跌的时候买在这没有走
凹单然后凹上去
我不确定是哪一种
那我就用我的理解来聊一下
你说4120出在4220
现在该如何重新等待切入的图
出在4220
你出在这里
我在猜是这个上影线
这些都是我猜的
因为我没有看到你的图
那我们就回到你的当下
4220这里
你出场了嘛你的当下土长这样子蛮足趋好出掉了怎麼進場就先不管反正你出掉了那要如何重新等待很簡單啊
你最一開始怎麼下單的
那因為我不知道你怎麼下單
如果是我們
回來嘛
看這個邊界
一開始是買4045出了再重新買
那你再重新買你是怎麼買
因为你会在4120的价格代表你应该不是用我们的方式
所以如果我是你
我的规划会是这样子
画一条线在这里
希望这边整理震荡下来在这附近
这是计划一
剧本一
第二个剧本
回来碰这个4180的位置
并且在这边走出
长出下影线
这是剧本二
有没有剧本三在这里
不会这个剧本3太靠近这边我就不碰
所以就只有剧本1你会来碰底下这里
剧本2碰这里
那中间这个呢这时候到时候再说吧
等行情来了再讲
那这个我就等他来碰
有没有碰
没有碰
没有碰我就不会吃
所以后面从4220这边
往上的这一整段我一张单都吃不到
我就会这样放着他
哇
没有我的
今天没有我要的回家
今天又没有我要的关机睡觉
又没有我要的睡觉
又没有我要的对一直睡
一直睡一直到什么时候符合我的两条线
尖尖的
或是说两条线在这边
他干脆都跌下来也好
跌到某个边界区域
我重新在这里等待我的破底翻
这样子
对啊
其實剛剛我們畫的兩條線邊界其實開始有出來
對吧
所以
其實就是用你新的角度
重新的畫得出兩條線的邊界
所以在4260這邊這是60分K的
我應該可以在5分K裡面找到平常我習慣的東西
理論上有
對吧
那就算沒有
這是小10K
我說不定可以在這個地方
找到5分K等級的
的壓力轉支撐在這個地方
在4275的附近
我不確定啦
因為我現在都是看著小時可以再講的
那現在呢
如果是现在我看到一大堆上影线
就不符合我做多的样子
那就不理他了
下一个问题
这个轻微同学
这个问题我留到最后
可以吗
我留到今天影片的最后面
我先把技术性的东西
这些一系列的讲完
你的比较偏心态面的东西
好不好
当下的4120有点急躁进单
给这位黄亚平同学
虽然你有赚钱
但是这个赚钱的前面
却是因为急躁进场
我不觉得这是一个长久之道
所以反而你要回头好好问自己
我能不能够三次五次的出手
然后就都固定的
做同一個邏輯同一個模式的出手
從三次開始就好
先有三次再來個五次
連續都固定的邏輯
原來拜託沒訂閱同學就是這位
我很難把這兩個東西連在一起
我們先把今天的聊完
我最後再回來聊這一張
那你很資深啊
打50张标准图会哭
不要啦
先三张就好了
三张光累积三次固定的出手
中间你的心态的煎熬
看到别人在各种摸
他赚钱
他各种怎么样
那个用均线
那个用KD赚钱
你的心里会痒到不行
这一段很难克服
但是一旦你过了
你就突然间发现
我就做我的美女就好了
这样好不好
来
边界哪个是对的
常常会有同学这样问我
例如说
例如
我用刚刚的小那
刚刚大家都在看小那
来来来来
我刚刚是有画两条线边界
对吧
来到下边界
如果你是做1K的
好
那很多同学会问我像这样子
5分K
会问说老于老于
到底是29850是压力
还是29860还是65还是870是压力還是870跟880到底哪一條壓力才是對的
注意哦
沒有對跟錯
但是我可以知道那個區域
是比較容易上不去或比較容易下不去的區域
對吧
這個區域是不是剛剛都是支撐
所以剛剛來到這附近代表這附近容易產生支撐
那反過來講上面勒
所以整區的角度我會把它框起來
框個有點厚度的框框
所以你怎麼講都對
而且再來
5分K看到的壓力支撐
是這附近這裡
5分K在這附近
然後15分K看到的勒
好像也在附近
這個案例有5分K15分K30分K
好像都在附近
有没有
那这个案例就代表这边有越来越多人使用
那这是个好事
代表这一条压力线
他们的军队很多人
很庞大
不容易一次就压得过
对吧
因为你要一次冲得过
除非你的军队可能是美股待会开盘
带着成交量才有足够的军队去冲破那个
那个城墙啊
对吧
那有没有某些支撑
例如這條支撐
這條線我先拿掉好了
看這邊
這條支撐
我到15K看
這裏有人用
但是當我拉到30K的時候我發現
這個支撐怎麼好像不是我
不是像上面的這個壓力線一樣
這麽乾乾淨淨
他一下子被這邊穿過來穿過去
這裡有支撐一下子 但是又被穿過去了
這裡到底有沒有啊
所以它的有效的能力就越來越低
所以在看邊界的時候有一個很重要的東西就是
來
最多開高低收碰到的價格貸
貸喔
那個貸就是我們觀察的東西
什麼意思
開高低收,一根K棒有四個價格
決定像這個引線的最邊邊是高點像這個實體K棒的邊界是開或是收对吧当你看到这样子的时候这里是不是你看有一个收盘价在这里有开盘价在这里最高价在这里
这里有一个最高价在这里有没有看到
所以代表这个区域是不是很多人用
那再宽一点点这里也很多人用
这个整个对过来
这里也很多人
最高价在这里
那我是不是这一整区
原来有点宽
所以就是这样子
很多人碰到的点
我这边要再继续延伸
不是只有这么简单的
既然最多人碰到的价格带
越多越有效
所以我就会喜欢做一件事
我先拉到这边来看
我喜欢在大颗度的边界
什么叫大颗度的边界
借我画图
假设是60分K的边界长这样子
其实我可以用今天的小拿
我先把这些给关掉一下好了
来注意看
我喜欢在60分K的边界
如果有机会让我在
注意看哦
60kk棒可能有引线在这里
有引线在这边
有一些边界这样子
如果我可以下单在60kk棒的
比较长的引线
短线的5分k
应该是长这样子
然后来到这里对不对
所以如果隔壁一根
长上来一些些又下来
它的k棒是不是大概会长这样子
有一些上引线
然后有一些下引线
对吧
那这整个60K画起来
就是这样子
在中间震荡
打下来回来的什么东西
这里你看到什么了
你看到什么
破底翻
这个我们讲很多遍了
对吧
好
继续的浓缩
你去看我下单的价格
尤其是
我用EK来当案例很好的案例
去看我下单的概念
看这个我很喜欢下单在开高低收刚刚好在这个实体K棒与引线K棒的交界处
我超爱
你知道为什么吗
因为如果有用程式交易的人
大家就知道
程式交易
他们常常是在前一根K棒走完了
买或是卖
在下一根K棒的开盘价
market
有在完成式交易的人应该都知道
当他要的数据确定了
5 4 3 2 1
收下一个open的那个价格
就是market
市价就直接吃进去
所以
简单的说
收盘价跟开盘价
是我们很喜欢的东西
那我们来聊心理学哦
注意看我这边
看这里
这里是不是跌破了一个
一个从下午2点30分
一路到3点快30分
这一个小时的边界
跌破了这么多的边界
理论上要把所有的这些成交量的多单逼出来
让它停损
有没有逼
有
1500口的成交量
有把这些逼出来
但是逼出来理论上应该要像这个一样
像上面这样子
這個應該這樣子講
來注意看喔
我這邊講很細
雖然是1K請大家把這個觀念放到其他等級的K棒
5K 15K 60分K全部都通用
來看這裡
跌破的時候理論上K棒應該要長這樣子
應該要跌下來然後它停損
每個停損都出來就下去了
應該長這樣子
對吧
但是該發生應該下去卻
卻變成一個買進邊界
注意
買進邊界很重要
那個心理上面的壓力
本來做多要停損的人
他本來如果留在下面多一秒鐘
他可能就要停損了
但是突然间有个大户买进来
买进这个边界以内
所有做多的人在看的边界
边界,有没有看到边界内
进来了
本来要停损子,他突然间有
本來要停損了 不停損了
那這時候說不定他還開始做多加碼
攤平我不管 對吧
你懂我意思嗎
心理層面的恐慌會突然間不見
會有點有希望
那是不是要跳車的人少一個
那賣壓就少一個啊
懂意思吧
那這個感覺會傳染給整個在船上的人
他也覺得可以不用賣
哎呦回來了好價格回來了
好當然有可能下一秒鐘就直接蹦吧
讓這些人全部再再哭一次當然
但是就是這個動作
這個動作這裡
這樣
怎麼不放棄那些摸單
因為我一邊在教學
我看到幾分K
我就直接按
我就按給他們看說
這個當時我在按的是按這樣子下來滿足區域
又在這個區域
然後我當時跟他們說我在看的是看這樣子大顆度的破底翻
這樣子好不好
來
這個是說那我吃在這個地方反正我是拿我自己的這個部位我來教學用
就這樣子反正就算做錯也不會錯太多
就這樣吧
來我要繼續囉
所以刚刚的这些东西
注意看现在在5K
这里正好有一个很好的案例
边界在这里对不对
如果等一下边界破了
如果等一下边界美股开盘时间破了
快速拉回来
是不是会让60分K也跟着变成一个
一个
一个有下影线的60分K
对吧
那如果这个向影线下来又收回去
回到边界的内部尖尖的很长
那隔壁这边可以期待
它小颗度放大
小颗度里面大概就是这个小破番
长在这个地方长在这里
这样子有看得懂吗
好不好
所以我就可以等待
哦原来有那个力量
我就顺着那个力量
就不要再说我们是逆势交易
我们其实是顺着
我们是逆着大科度的边界没错
但是我们在边界等行情回到跟我同一边的地方我才跟著下單所以呢幫大家收斂一下結論
你找到邊界的時候有最多開高低收有沒有
這樣子還不打緊我需要的是什麼
需要的是某一根K棒的
時薪跟這個引線的交界
正好在我要下單的地方
我需要這個
有這個的隔壁
我很好做計劃
這邊我很好做計劃
匡起來打擊區出現了
太棒了
如果沒有來我找一個沒有的案例
我找一個沒有的案例是
如果呢
如果如果如果如果如果
很難找很難找
你看我早上8點鐘
我第一個是部位
這個部位也是我那時候下那個
IB那邊的部位
我也是下在同一個點
你有沒有看到我下單的位置來在哪裡
是不是在引線跟這個小破番的總和區的交界處
有看到這件事情嗎
這個很重要很重要喔
好不好
如果我是下單在第五
看我喔 如果我是下單在這裡
這個位置 那就尷尬了
因為這個位置往左邊對過去
它是前波的高架 這兩個高架在這裡
雖然事後看它都是上去的 沒錯
但是那是事後看 我不喜歡下單在上偏K棒的上面
也不喜歡下單在我的正左邊這裡沒有參考點
熟悉我的同學應該都知道我喜歡下單在這種地方
尤其是交界出
因為這樣我很好做防守
很好做進攻
這就是我習慣的動作
這樣
好不好
目標也是金錢進場點跟我一模一樣
YES
我那個單子還在
這個
這個就是在這裡
這裡
然後我這邊下單的邏輯很簡單吧
這個
那我其實當初我在想說
我要不要直接五口再敲一次五口進去想想不要啦我才還在復健而已才在把自己从那种那种大幅度想赚钱就错过那个行鞋的心态拉回来
所以我就好吧
不然就加个一口一石一下
这样子而已
对啊
我就等开盘了
我要等翻上去啊
然后今天看到有一个
我觉得是日线
我觉得很有机会的东西
MU
我現在看到的是日線這邊越來越窄
越來越窄對不對
對啊
但是這個窄
你看一下這個邊界
喔
所以他其實蠻
蠻有機會的
這樣子
我現在看到的是像這種
噴了就會往下噴
哇
而且是說日線在這個地方
我也沒有很愛啊
噴了那就等吧
等
我剛剛是不是說會戳下來會有個60K
群光的日K
我們看一下群光號碼幾號
群光我用搜尋的好了
日K
群光的日K
前幾天是但今天不是
前幾天邊界
來來來來來來
這是個好案例
邊界打破尖尖的隔壁
今天不行的,今天已經是整個邊界已經處在中間的
現在這個價格104
這樣
好吧
不要這樣啦
這個破底盤這麼漂亮,你給我噴出去喔
哇同學的這個
STIM這個噴翻的
這是新的GameStop是不是
媽呀
MU
剛有同學問我說MU是不是上影線
這些上影線我知道上影線很多
但是你看一下
你看到的是上影線
我看到的是下影線
兩邊都有話說對不對
那既然兩邊都有話說
就看誰的角度
这边这个角度
跟这边这个角度谁比较猛烈好像做多的力量稍微强了一些些我们在60分K这里看得出来这样子看
所以短线这个边界
来这边又来了
60K尖尖的隔壁
有没有看到这种事情
所以这种尖尖的隔壁这件事情
其实一再的在不同的刻度都有在发生
Intel是不是
Int intc
日线
是不是也跟MU很像
相對起來他的圖我覺得反而還比MU更漂亮
比美光
我為什麼會這樣講
因為他的圖的這個穩定性
它比较有那个由上往下去踩
踩这个边界这里
这里
而且踩了大概12345个交易日了
目前在踩这里
这样
所以它比他们来的更好看
这样讲好了
My steam may kill me
这时候肯定没说了一声
WDC
是不是很美的边界二的范例
曾经很美
但是现在情忘掉原来的边界二
为什么会这样讲
因为照道理讲
不过其实他这个下引线收得太近去
他如果收在这个边界超美
你现在你说边界二的范例
除非你拉到周线可能会很漂亮的东西
哦呦周线很漂亮
但是日线
日线这个位置有点尴尬
因为它稍微偏
比较偏这些地方
这样
然后底下这个尖尖的照道理讲
这么尖哦
这里这么尖的东西
理论上隔壁这几天
他就要這樣子像這樣子一樣
應該要出去
所以回來這裡鬼混
如果是像這樣子
我不會太認真的去吃他
我可能會稍微
稍微緩一點點
這樣
因為我覺得上面畫到什麼
要多畫一條
等一下再來取消好了
好不好
CRM
利基電好等一下看一下利基電跟CRM
C
等一下CRM用這裡看
我這裡有啊
上週買在
你買在哪裡
183周縣滿足區
等一下
周縣我的單子被洗掉了
沒了
沒有真的賺到但是也沒有賠到
好啦賭失敗
那這個賭失敗
現在的我要特別跟自己講話
賭失敗我就不要再亂按
因為我之前錯過
現在這個賭失敗我會不會整個心裡面
哇嗚到不行
所以最好的方式是離開個半個小時
讓自己遠離他
然後半個小時後再回來
要嘛給我噴出要嘛怎麼樣
反正都不關我的事
我不要在這個時候待在
剛被燒掉有情緒的我的這個地方
這樣好不好
來然後
所以CRM你剛剛說的我有沒有看錯啊
183滿族區買喔
你是賣嗎
183周線滿族區
我不太懂你講的概念
你是因為
如果你買在183這裡
可能不會是我所習慣的買點
對啊
給這位問CRM的同學
你可以告訴我一下嗎
但是怎麼會是買在滿足區
周縣
你應該是買在這裡吧
如果你應該是買在底下160這裡吧
是183是163吧
如果是买在这边
来一样
周线尖尖的隔壁
打击区就是这个区域这样子
那这里同时间也是破底翻的打击区
有没有同样的概念
对吧
你应该不是买在这里吧
如果你买在这边来
那我好好跟你聊一下不要用滿足區的概念來買不要千萬不要 因為這不是一個適合
它就是兩條線
所以上面這邊是你敲鑼打鼓叫別人買別人幫你撞破那個城牆
不要自己買
我們的做法是買在像這種我們所熟悉的底下的位置
讓市場在那邊自己有能力往上突破就好了
好不好
把我點掉就回來是怎樣
你可以這麼哇不要看了
哭哭
哎呦看來我們講的這個Sandisk
其實也是Sandisk的圖跟那個美光的概念是一樣的
就是在這個邊界我看到好多下不去的樣子
剛剛有同學說要看立即電對不對
立即電我記得
立即
G...
不对,是这个啦,6770吧,应该是这个
是这个利基店
来
你要问我什么
上面问利基店的,有吗?在哪里?在哪里?在哪里?
4968立基是不一樣的東西 49
4968不一樣的東西這個
破底翻手尖尖的下面預計亞當翻一倍出場
亞當翻一倍就是這裡這樣子到這樣子出場對不對
我覺得如果你有能力吃在這個地方
翻一倍 OK 但是不要全出
因為你吃的位置相對起來是周線
剛好就是周線 很漂亮的尖尖的隔壁這種地方
如果你這邊翻一個短短的這樣出場 這才日K而已
如果他不小心就從這邊開始這樣一路走出去
對吧 你留著那個底單 你後面要再加碼 其實很好加
好不好 買的點很好短線的這個我覺得他有這一段96到100也不過才4塊錢就是4塊翻出去8塊
96到8塊大概連10%都不到
我會覺得賺賠比稍微沒有到那麼美麗
所以說短出一下不要全出
這樣好嗎
AMD
是不是可以開始等等看有沒有尖尖的
這裡對不對
你是不是在講這個破底翻的概念對不對
應該可以哦
等一下我看一下
短線這個小時不能再往下
他必須要想辦法收進
差不多就是現在不能再繼續跌了
如果能回到460
可能68啦69啦
470這樣對多投資是反而比較有利
但是短線看起來目前還在往這邊等喔
平平的斜斜的目前的力量還在往下
但是你可以觀察剛剛我講的那個點這樣
OK
然後嘛
然後剛剛好像有人要看台積電對不對
好
TSM
你要我看他的ADR是不是
看了一下上面平平下面斜斜
其實很容易往這邊出去
你去看一下前面
前面這種概念
上面平平下面斜斜
對吧
出去了
又一次
这边
然后这里又来
上面平平
下面斜斜
咻
上去了
上面平平
下面平平
那就看哪边斜吧
又上去了
所以这边就是斜
往这边
往这边这样子
有没有看到
所以现在
我目前看到的
有没有跟我刚刚前面画的东西都很像
然后反过头来
下跌之前
来下跌之前
这个下跌之前
上面斜斜下面平平的
然后就咚
有没有
我们把交易法讲完了
就这么简单只是你不相信这么简单而已好吗我过去
我去日本玩的这段时间
我完全没有下单
所以那个特斯拉在底下什么的
我就完全没有吃到
就苦苦
谁叫我要挑七月底跑去日本
就这么刚好
很多好的行情都发生在那个地方
然后一回来
我上禮拜不是感冒吗
对不对
所以一回来没多久就生病
所以我又休息了好一段时间
现在才恢复正常
恢复正常
现在很多行情在上面有没东西做
那怎么办
就这样
PLT要吃在112
超欠揍的
112对不对
是不是这里
是不是那个日线的那里
对不对
哇
正常来讲你吃在120的这些
120几的这些PLTR
都超美
希望把它嘎爆
我也帮大家祝念一下
嘎上去
30块
感谢你
你知道吗
其实之前还有同学会
会抖内比较多的金额
我常常都会
例如说
大家不要玩哦
你不要玩我
就是人家DNN可能3000块
我就加3000
然后凑在一起直接DNN
就直接结一个DNN的记录
我就捐出去给人家
所以你不要这样
我还要被call
你这个DNN
我收不到全额
这种金额
YouTube他们本身要抽30%的钱
所以我只拿到一些设计成
但是我是全额加起来
就DNN出去的
不要跟我嗨啦
感谢你
台达店日K买在7月3号
台达店
台达店我记得我这边好像有
台达店这里
你买在7月
等一下
是8月3号还是7月3号
看在哪里
日K
买在7月3号
等一下
7月3号在这里
你怎么没有
這一大段怎麼都沒有走到1500都沒有走
你確定你講對還是8月3號
對啊
我能舉例更多應該上去卻沒上去
那種盤桿嗎
可以啊等一下我來到短線看一下好不好
我介紹短線的
如果是這樣子
想問何時能逃
好问题
那我问你
如果你现在想着何时能逃
那你买在7月3号吗
你买在这一天
我不管你买在哪里
你买在高点这边这边
隔壁这几天有机会逃
你怎么不逃这两天
有机会逃
甚至这一天跌破了你的这个成本
怎么不逃
我在猜应该是想要赚更多
想要凹回去
想说一点点小亏损
结果放着放着就一路亏下来了
对吧
那给这位套牢的同学
套牢分几种
如果你是一千万里面的一百万拿来玩
然后玩套牢的
我没意见随便你套吧
那这时候如果是这样子
我就跟你讲说
好啊你就等他翻亚当翻上去
再来解套吧
这样子
如果你是这样子
因为你有本跟他拗
我不是说你1000万里面
其他900万都买了其他股票
然后这100万买在台达店
台达店100万买不起
要180万
反正你就是等比例
那些钱
我的意思是
你是1000万里面
其他的900是现金
摆在那边不能动的
你只下了100万的钱
那随便你
我没意见
这是一种
另外一种是
如果这个钱对你来讲是很重要的
那你打从最一开始就不应该凹啊
是吧
打从最一开始就不应该凹
所以今天你现在问我
什么时候能解套
我觉得这是一个强人所难的题目
因为我不像网路上面的一些分析师
他们会跟你讲说
这个明天就上去
这个一定怎么样
我说不出来
我连我自己的小娜
我都搞不定了
来
我的小娜跌到600多我连我自己的小娜在这边被打掉我都搞不定了
如果我知道
我可以跟你讲
我先救我自己吧
对不对
对啊
所以我连下一秒钟会发生什么事
美股开盘会发生什么事
我都说不准
所以我没有办法给你答案
那这个答案在你心中
那如果你過去這段期間曾經有一絲絲害怕的想法
那我的建議是你明天就直接除掉
只要有一天你有害怕過
代表這個單子打從一開始根本不應該出現
那我問你啦
你說何時能解套如果接下來就這樣往這邊走
跌到1600
你是不是放著
放著
破了
既然破了就放著吧
所以你要買在2000塊或是1900
然後承受凹單到這裡嗎
到1400嗎
如果剛好出現大的利空
我不知道啊
到1300甚至到1000
不要跟我說不可能哦
看看微信看看宏達店
對吧
所以你要想的是如果下去怎麼辦
所以我的建议是
既然都给你回来了
你已经少赔了
你只从这边赔到这里
我的建议是
这一段的亏损
你就明天承认它
虽然我觉得可能再上去的几率
越来越高
没错
因为目前都还在往这边走
但是因为你的进场点不对
这笔单当初就不应该出现在这里
那你就承认这个亏损
然后让这个亏损成为你
心中一个很重要的痛
有那个痛
你就会开始觉得
好 我好像应该要遵守一些纪律
我好像应该要干嘛
你才会够痛
你才会开始做一些对的事情
人都是这样子
虽然我在念你
但是我也在念以前的我自己
这种单子我拗过太多了
这样子
好不好
对啊 如果你是买
那如果你是当初买在这边的人
他们一定也有人套牢到这里
买在2400套牢到1500
哭到不行
这已经不对等你套牢到了某个程度你的心会突然间从很紧张的感觉突然间放宽心没关系啦
就长期投资吧
放着不要看吧
吃饭
喝饮料
吃冰都没事
因为每天过得很开心
出去玩
对
然后承受一个很大的亏损
刚开始套牢很紧张
等你套牢了三四十%以后
你就会放宽心
对不对
就是这样吧
套牢好几趴
那就是要不是开杠杆
对如果有开杠杆哦
如果你是要包含着
例如说借来的钱
或是你是去买那种两倍的那种商品
三倍的商品
这会很恐怖好不好
好來回答一下3135看一下3135
問什麼呢?昨天吃中午163的價格算是好的互換跟破販
可以啊!可以啊!我覺得沒什麼問題啊!OK!
那我看一下喔!中午喔!好!所以大概就是這附近可以啦!
那我要问的是问那你预计做到哪里
我猜你可能是预计做到上面这附近
我猜
把这一段小短短的这一段先做到这边先来个短出
然后把这段翻出去
如果有机会来到这附近可能第二阶段的目标
那你心中要而底哦
这边其实有个短短的压力
在前一天这里这个上引线
这个上影线
然后这里有个本来的边界下影线这里
所以你心中要有底
他这边还会震荡一段时间
因为他上面还有这一段
所以可能还是会回到你的成本价
在这边鬼混
好不好
我觉得这没有什么问题
只要这个边界不要破掉
可以稍微回来到160
但是如果再往下你心中要有底
这个有可能就不太对了
然後我螢幕上面有9921
我覺得很好玩
這個我不知道大家記不記得
如果你有回去挖今年大概在3、4月、4、5月附近的新聞捷安特的新聞全部都是超級負面的新聞
我不知道大家記不記得
就是什麼他們的業績衰退
各個國家的銷量減少
腳踏車的熱潮退了
什麼現在外面的那種租借腳踏車的這麼多誰要買腳踏車
我不知道大家記不記得
這邊負面新聞超級超級多
一大堆
然後現在在這
超好笑的
這樣
來還有什麼
1514亞利
現在是可以觀察的邊界嗎
如果你用周線看可能
哇
現在代表102這個價格
這叫做現在嗎
有點尷尬耶
因為比較多開高低收來
今天才講過的東西
這一條邊界是不是比較乾乾淨淨
有沒有看到比較沒有東西突出去
頂多就只有他而已
就這個這個影線這裡
這樣但是現在這個102這裡
哇這個我不知道耶
我不知道
如果從日線來看邊界
尷尬了
我不是很會看這種
對啊
好不好
9914買在65.2
你買美麗達是不是
美麗達買在65.2
這種都要吊起來打
買東西不跟大家說
好單
吊起來打的好單
欠揍真的是
以後大家要記得
這些同學們
他們都偷偷躲起來買好的東西
買得很好
這個邊界買得很漂亮
这是炫耀文 可以续报吗
你问到续报就问倒我的 我只能跟你说
眼前很强 但是也是前一波的满足区
眼前告诉你这么强
但是同时也是前面的这一段
的满足區也有可能是這一段的满足區
又是壓力區
所以我覺得遇到震盪的機率其實蠻高的
這樣
所以你心中要有底哦
你要繼續出去可以
這邊會有一個可能上下好多塊錢的這種震盪
震盪往再噴那就整個出去了
這樣
有同學說得很好耶
問就是你想賣
是啊那你就適當的賣一些
如果你有10张就卖个5张
你有20张就卖个10张
剩下留一半赌上去就好了
27个月的新同学
那你明明就知道你自己要干嘛
买点很棒啊
真的是
这些
你们这些同学其实都很会做
还有问比特币
比特币下一个
等一下
1476的这个我要特别讲一下
这个
周线现在是不是值得观察
是值得观察的位置
但是太凶了
本周目前周一周二
有够凶
我觉得这张图
就算这边有出现边界
这张图没有很好做
因为它这个边界处在
整个大边界的中间
不是很好判断
连周线也是
这条线对过去
请问他有没有被其他的价格来
注意看
看我这条黄色的线有没有被价格穿过来
穿过去有没有
是不是被
没有很漂亮
对吧
如果哪一天价格跑到这里来
那就会跑到
注意看哦
如果价格哪一天跑到这里来
是不是这条线就会干净很多
这样有看到吗
有没有
這樣子的差別是這個短線有點兇
然後它又停的位置有點卡卡的
這個我會完全把它放掉這樣好嗎然後讓我留一点时间我答应那位同学要回答他的东西的我看完这个A股的
然后就来讲下一个
同学问很多我知道
然后呢
A股你问什么
在哪里啊
在哪里
在這邊
7月23日K買2.8
可以嗎
7月23
7月
可以啊
如果這不是破底翻
什麼是破底翻
可以啊可以啊
這個邊界很美
這跟剛剛最一開始的那個
STIM
那個Steam那支股票
有異曲同工之妙
很美买的很好
没有什么问题
赞
我的小娜
小娜
你看我刚刚停损
如果我没有
我没有离开电脑
我没有跟大家在讲课
我说不定后面这边立刻又看到
尖尖的隔壁又吃进去
然后又被停损一次
会哦
然后我就觉得可恶
然后又这边可能又摸又停损又怎么样
对吧
好那眼前我先这样子我先来回答
刚刚同学的那个
有人说steam这个哇长46%
这是啥挖沟太夸张了
看到同學們這麼厲害
我都要躲到地上去
Microsoft今天出光了
好啦就是
我就不再回答同學的東西了
如果其他同學有看到
這樣我在好不好
15K如果收上去可以摸嗎
我看一下15K
15K收上去,有收進來了
不要追著摸,請你等他回來的摸所以可能45K停了等他震盪一下這樣我不要追著摸好不好不要說隔壁立刻可以吃因為這裡有這個點
我把那個先拿掉
這裡有這個
我不是很明確
我不是很確定說這個邊界到底怎麼樣
如果他是有這樣子回來的這裡
我反而會比較好判斷破敵翻
這樣好不好
現在的話你可能頂多是用
了不起你用小10k的角度去摸这个边界
但是你的防守坦白讲我觉得很难守
因为有这个人
这个人在这里我觉得
你守这里也不对
守这里也不对
这又太远
小10k这边很好吃没错
那你唯一的防守就是这里
就是你要堵他这件事情
这样好不好
那我呢
我没有吃在那个关键的边界
我就懶得动了
等他一下吧
反正这个小时刚开始
看他等一下鬼混成怎么样再说
我来回答这个同学的问题
同学说
这个怀疑跟自信
是不是跟贪婪跟恐惧一样
大恶恋交易因
你应该就是那个吧
就是拜托别订阅同学
大四毕业
确实在TS跟台股美股都有赚到钱
所以怀疑自己是不是运气好
很多改的缺点
然后等等
大家先看一下我聊的
同学你很年轻
对吧
所以我说了
我在你这个年纪的时候
大家应该都知道吧
我们那个年代
大概暗黑破坏神
对
那时候暗黑就是从
暗黑二
我在五专大学那个年纪
我没有念大学
反正就是那个时候
开始玩
我从那时候魔兽
我从40等级40的魔兽世界开始玩
然后一路玩到后来
中间就我现在完全没玩了
我觉得那太花时间了
小时候才有时间
学校的妹子跟老鱼
你选择了老鱼
去交个女朋友啦
你交个女朋友就没有这么多时间打单了
快点去交个女朋友
然後注意看我說的喔
在前進的過程不用一直想著我是不是可以或不可以幹嘛不用你就繼續往前走好了我用棒球當舉例最近那個美國大聯盟到期的那位Mookie Bet
他遇到一個算是生涯以來
算是很少見的這種低潮
打也打不好怎麼樣
他連他自己接受訪問的時候
他自己也說
我也不知道發生什麼事
他說I don't know
I have no idea
他自己這樣講
然後
他的角度就是他現在就是好好的做訓練
做他原本該做的事
把他繼續往前走
先暫時忘記他的教練也跟他講
先暫時忘記這些事情
你只要回歸到你原來的訓練
市場會還給你的
你可能只是暫時怎麼樣怎麼樣
你越想哦
注意哦
你在這個時候如果你越想
哇我有沒有走出去
我有沒有走出去
你越想反而越走不出去
你反而会越陷在里面
所以我不管你现在是在怀疑也好
自信也好
对
重点摆在你眼前的人生
或是当下的这个交易
你把该做的事情做好
你的人生或是你的学业
你把该做的做好
这样
你比昨天烂也没关系
比昨天好也没关系
反正就把今天的当下
给做好
这样
好吗
所以你说
要不要把这个当成是自己前进的动力
我觉得你不用想那么多
我觉得把交女朋友当成前进的动力
是个
对吧
各位这是个很好的提议
对不对
对吧
把你的重心
我要怎么样去关心女生
对不对
所以这个壮强情
你不要管那么多
你就闷着头做
像最早期
Jack有一段时间
他说他也有一些心理的问题
他说我要调整
Jack现在会不会耳朵痒痒的
Jack不要骂我
反正你自己也拿出来讲过
我就拿出来讲
那时候
他说他自己觉得心里面卡卡的
不敢下单或怎么样
然后我就跟他讲说
反正你就是照着做
不管眼前的这个图是钻石培
反正有你就打没有就不打就这样子
然后专注在你能不能够把图继续的这样打过去
那你也不要管你今天是不是走出去的
老虞我可能要停下来思考一下
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:20:00 起〕